With the release of the Android
M Developer Preview SDK,
developers are
jumping in to make
sure their apps are up to date
with changes in the framework.
I'm Wojtek Kalicinski,
and I'll show you
how new features that we're
introducing in Android Studio
1.3 can help you
with the transition.
The single biggest
change in Android M
is the overhaul of
the permission system.
From now on, before
using certain APIs,
you need to make
sure your app asks
for the necessary
permissions during runtime.
But given the large
code base, how do you
know which methods actually
require this special handling?
In Android Studio 1.3, we're
adding a [? lint rule ?]
that detects methods
marked with a new "requires
permissions" annotation
from the support library.
The editor will
now highlight code
that uses permissions which
are missing from your Android
manifest.
Moreover, if it detects
you haven't performed
the necessary runtime
check in your code,
it will suggest a quick fix.
Static code analysis
like this can
help you catch common
programming mistakes
even before you run your app
on the device or emulator.
The "requires
permission" annotation
is actually defined
in the support library
and works in tandem with a
Link Checker in Android Studio.
Let's go through some
other annotations
that you will find in
the latest release.
Threading annotations guard
you against calling methods
on the wrong thread.
Let's say you're doing
some background processing,
like in this AsyncTask example.
Because the AsyncTask methods
are already properly annotated,
the IDE will alert
you if you try
changing the UI from
here by calling methods
on the text view instance.
On the other hand,
Android Studio
knows it's safe to invoke
UI code in unpost execute,
as it is marked with the
main thread annotation.
Up next, the size and range
annotations for integers
and floats.
They can be used for controlling
the length of your arrays
and strings, or making sure a
number is in a specified range.
They're especially handy for
annotating method parameters,
so that the caller
can immediately
know what kind of
values are expected.
If you want to study
those in more detail,
as well as learn about other
annotations, like check result
and call [? super, ?] click
through to the documentation
here.
Remember that you don't have
to rely on the annotations
that we've included in
the Android framework.
You are free to add them to
your own methods and classes
so that anyone
using your code will
benefit from the
additional checks performed
by Android Studio.
Speaking of sharing
code, Android Studio 1.3
introduces support for hiding
resources in library modules.
Perhaps it's easiest to
demonstrate on an example.
Here's what used to happen when
you tried to use autocompletion
in a Layout file when you have
appcompat in your dependencies.
And here is the
same operation using
the newest versions of both
studio and the support library.
Most of the resources
we see on the left
are used internally by the
creators of the library
and were never meant
to be available
for third-party developers.
Not only do they
introduce clutter
and pollute your
project's name space,
things might also
break with any update
if you decide to use
them in your layouts.
To define which resources
should be visible
for users of your
library, simply
put a public XML file
in your values folder.
Provide an entry containing the
type and name of each resource
you want to set as public.
This information will also
be bundled and available
to Android Studio if
you decide to distribute
your library in AAR format.
With the release of 1.3,
we're bringing more tools
that were previously available
as external applications
into Android Studio.
You can now open your
object allocation
trace files in the new
allocation tracker, which
shows you a visual overview
of where allocations
happen in your code,
and gives you a way
to dig right into the data.
Another memory inspection
tool that is now available
right in the IDE
is the HPROF viewer
for opening hprof profiles.
It gives you access
to the reference tree
of any object in memory, as
well as a property inspector,
similar to the variable
debugger window.
Use it to examine
the state of objects
at the moment when the
memory snapshot was taken,
and to track down any rogue
references that prevent them
from being garbage collected.
By the way, we've also
added small improvements
in the traditional
debugger interface.
From now on, when you inspect a
variable that holds a resource
identifier, you can easily
see the human-readable name
instead by switching to the
Android typed integer view.
There are many more new
features in Android Studio 1.3--
integration with the
data binding library,
adding developer services from
the project structure dialogue,
live code templates,
and finally,
a preview of the upcoming
C/C++ editing and NDK support
in the IDE.
So upgrade Android Studio
now, and as always,
please report any bugs in
our Google+ community here.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]